this is a government clinic in Malaysia
where vaccinations are given free for 12
preventable major childhood diseases
including measles diphtheria and polio
immunization coverage has reached 95
percent but the program isn't mandatory
and Mohammed Norman Zakaria a father of
two has chosen not to vaccinate his
children they do believe that nasal
sampling
I do believe the measles is not a deadly
disease because if we look at the older
generation how did they deal with it
somehow we're treating all these
diseases that have existed for a long
time as something that's so deadly and I
believe that with good sanitation good
hygiene good nutrition and existing
information you can treat measles at
least for my child that's my personal
stand but I don't go around telling
parents not to vaccinate their kids
reason cited by other parents for not
vaccinating include concerns about
possible adverse side effects and
religious grounds this debate is taking
place not only in Malaysia but globally
the World Health Organization has blamed
vaccine misinformation as a major threat
to global health saying it could reverse
progress made in tackling preventable
diseases
one example is measles provisional data
from the wh0 indicates there have been
more measles cases reported worldwide in
the first half of this year than in any
year since 2006 the rise in measles
cases is driven by poverty in some
places but in more developed countries
is due to a growing wave of people who
refuse immunization for their children
in Malaysia the Health Ministry says the
number of anti-vaxxers as they're known
is small but the government is
considering a proposal to make certain
vaccinations compulsory for children we
all agree that our children must not be
exposed to such unnecessary risk
especially when there is vaccination
available and it's free for the children
in Malaysia Amir Arif as me and his wife
are expecting their first child next
month and they've decided they'll follow
the national immunization schedule not
just about protecting your child it's
about protecting others as well because
if we can ensure that every child who
can vaccinate be vaccinated
we might prevent all these diseases from
spreading he says to deny that to any
child would be irresponsible
Florence lui al Jazeera Kuala Lumpur